[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
paphos au verbe trois personnalités dont
nous allons parler valérie pécresse qui
sont va donc la représentante de la
droite aux élections présidentielles
eric zemmour qui a fait son premier
meeting et puis et puis on nous
reviendrons sur la sphère nicolas hulot
qui pose des problèmes à la fois
moureaux judiciaire très intéressant
c'est donc ces trois sujets que nous
allons aborder dans cette émission avec
laurence mercadé choqué bonjourbonjour
patrice est avocate au barreau de
versailles il ya un autre avocat il
s'appelle geoffrey meyer bonjour mon
jean patrice avocat au barreau de
versailles secrétaire de la conférence
du stage
raphaël mata duvignau qui est maître de
conférences à l'université de versailles
saint quentin va nous rejoindre dans
quelques instants jean charles lajoie
denis qui est éditeur et bonjour bonjour
ça va bien pas mal quand même pas mal et
alors aux visions avec nous à une paire
brio bonjour bonjour patrice alors vous
êtes cette commune dit quand vous étiez
vous avez été conseiller régional d'île
de france 2 on peut le dire proche de
valérie pécresse pour ça pourquoi
aujourd'hui vous vous avez un verre de
petits dés que vous buvez
à côté de vous et puis vandry de guerre
peu de mon jour
vous êtes vous êtes étudiant et vous
êtes-vous
l air l air mais membre aussi de la
génération sait danser ça
et vous étiez vous étiez au meeting de
zemmour oui j'ai été une nation vous me
raconterez tout ça on va commencer par
deux pas de premier sujet c'est donc la
désignation de valérie pécresse comme
candidate de la droite c'est donc elle
[Musique]
alors valérie pécresse d'enquêté
désignée après ces primaires internes à
la droite au deuxième tour face à face à
eric ciotti
je vais commencer par vous albert boyau
est-ce que c'était une c'était une
victoire que vous souhaitiez est ce que
vous vous y attendiez
alors je suis évidemment très heureuse
parce que je connais la force et la
sincérité de l'engagement que valérie
pécresse
et puis si vous voulez bon c'est vrai
qu'il ya quand même un ensemble de
points important à signaler d'abord un
congrès qui s'est extrêmement bien
déroulé avec 5 candidats de talent qui
ont pu montrer leur différence et qui a
été très complémentaires
alors effectivement comme vous le dites
patrice des sondages à nouveau quelle
leçon pour les sondages qui donnaient
bertrand et barnier en tête et en fait
c'est pécresse et ciotti qui sont sortis
du chapeau donc à nouveau un gros doute
sur la fiabilité des sondages ça c'est
sûr et puis après ben on a vu que ce
sont des débats qui ont vraiment pesé
des débats de bon niveau qui ont pesé et
on a pu voir que valérie pécresse
connaissait parfaitement bien ses
dossiers avait une détermination et une
énergie sans faille on peut aussi dire
que c'est le pire scénario
attendu par emmanuel mac ou qui avait
tout fait pour que xavier bertrand soit
son adversaire et
parce qu'il redoutait valérie pécresse
s'était assez assez clair
alors on a vu aussi qu'au lendemain de
de sa victoire elle détenait déjà les
oppositions donc ça aussi c'est un bon
signe et puis enfin c'est vrai que c'est
là la première femme de la droite
républicaine candidate à une élection
présidentielle
et on voit que la dynamique a fonctionné
puisque comme vous l'avez tous lui dans
les sondages aller à + 7 % 17 % est
désormais tout à fait crédible sur sa
présence un second tour face à emmanuel
macron voilà
peut-être commentaires sur le sur la
campagne solo parce qu'elle s'est quand
même été une campagne alors ce qui
s'adressait aux militants de l est mais
quitter une campagne très à droite qui
étaient essentiellement centrés sur la
sécurité et sur l'immigration
très à droite je sais pas à droite
tweetesque qu'est ce que c'est que très
à droite si c'est des thèmes qui vous
plaisent pas on dit très à droite c'est
des thèmes qui sont importants
l'immigration
voici les thèmes de beaucoup de gens ces
thèmes du tout le monde ça va être le
thème de macron bientôt ça va peut-être
certaines obligatoire mais juste avant
de revenir là dessus je pense que c'est
aussi un truc est patent pour christian
jacob que tout le monde a toujours un
peu méprisé critiques et aux deux ans
voilà il n'est pas très bon et cetera
quand il a annoncé cette primaire avec
des résultats le 4 décembre tout le
monde a dit mais c'est une catastrophe
les de la droite est fichue ils sont pas
aperçus qu'ils veulent une élection
présidentielle la république est en fait
est un truc qui fait passer
remarquablement bien
et en même temps c'est 150 mille votants
faut pas non plus dire on en fait tout
un plat m'enfin c'est pas les 3 millions
de votants qu'avec avait désigné cerphi
mais ils vont pas inventé non plus des
nouveaux
vos militants donc il ya un seul homme
de militants donc c'est cette série est
intéressant c'est de retour peut-être à
travers sa des partis politiques
d'ailleurs j'espère parce que je touche
tout ce soit à gauche comme à droite
c'est tout à fait 5 et des partis
politiques on voit ce que ça donne il ya
des macros et bien évidemment des tas de
deux côtés positifs mais mais cette
déconstruction de 2 to le l'univers
politique et est pas très très bonne ça
donne ça donne des défilés jaune ça
donne des scènes donnent des tonnes de
choses catastrophiques
et voilà ben je moi je je me félicite du
retour des républicains sur le sol sur
le devant de la scène et peut-être un
jour ma parti de gauche parle pas avant
une dizaine d'années je pense à
des gens qu'on dise 12 ans maintenant
qu'ils vont être brillant dans dix ans
que
moi je trouve que déjà c'est plutôt bien
que ce soit que ce soit une femme mais
je pense que ça va être très compliqué
pour elle
c'était sur le congrès sur le web le
vote les surprises quand même parce que
c'est quand même on oublie ses gommes
ciotti qui était en tête j'y croyais pas
trop que parce qu'il est tellement
tellement très très très très à droite
et avec des points de convergence avec
avec zemmour donc je me disais que dans
les lr s'ils veulent avoir quelqu'un qui
soit à droite sans pour autant glissé
troppo santoro glissé trop trop à droite
valérie pécresse était bien dans le bon
créneau et j'étais voilà j'étais pas
très inquiète sur le fait que
des heureux mais il va passer il a
possédé
et valérie pécresse d'ailleurs je
trouvais assez habilement plutôt que
dirait il a une grotte et maurienne le
compare à pasqua ce qui passe qui est
assez adroit quoi parce que pasqua et
elle avait une grande
autorité popularité parmi les parmi des
militants du rpr à l'époque
et puis ça plaît beaucoup à beaucoup de
gens relativement âgés c'est bien aussi
comme référence voilà après culture des
humoristes de bas de gamme qui rappelle
toujours pasqua le pastis le voilà donc
ça non mais c'est quelqu'un qui se
dessine parmi les militants
le dessus alors concernant valérie
pécresse c'est vrai qu'elle a eu cette
première chose c'est vrai que les les
sondages sont souvent déjoué lorsqu'il
s'agit de primaire qu'elle soit havrais
en tout cas le sourire c'était très
compliqué la soirée internautes c'est
vrai
qu'il y avait en plus écopé de lucidité
pour les relais son double spécificité
que c'était alors ça venait après une
primaire qui avait ce qu'ils s'étaient
bien déroulés en 2016 mais qui avait mis
le candidat quand même face à une
certaine forme de difficulté puisqu'elle
avait une grosse edgy timité populaire
mais derrière il avait du mal à
rassembler son propre camp nonobstant
les difficultés judiciaires j'avais
beaucoup plus beaucoup
ça avait été très compliqué pour autant
et pour le coup ça va aussi être bon on
en parlera peut-être après une de ces
difficultés ça va être de rassembler
véritablement le parti
valérie pécresse elle revient
relativement de loin parce que elle
avait quitté les républicains de mémoire
on la définissait comme étant macron
compatibles donc il fallait réussir à
capter le vote des adhérents et l'air et
il faut admettre que c'est une femme
politique de grand talent et qu' elle
l'a fait de manière absolument
remarquable et est trop clairement là à
mon avis pas volé pas volé du tout du
tout sa victoire mais mais même si
effectivement
elle a bénéficié d'une belle victoire
elle va avoir je pense un certain nombre
de difficultés parce que même si ce
congrès s'est bien déroulée mais ici à
l'appui des marseillais l'appui des
militants il va falloir pour elle
réussir a quand même mais enfin dit ses
soli fiévreux solidifier toute cette
base 7% on verra ce qui se fait un
procès concernant son bilan mais il y en
a d'autres qui la donnent à 13,1 donc la
dot mais il
faut faire attention servi jours la
donne et a89 dit
récemment dans le monde ça existe je
salue raphaël mata duvignau qui nous a
rejoints pour jour bon je m'attriste
plongé à tous et de coopers et déjà cité
de verser 50 justement avec et ont signé
six ans pau justement avec vous je
voulais aborder le au four il y avait
des vies trois droites de rené rémond
l'ailé droite légitimiste bonapartiste
et organiste ça un peu changé mais il ya
en impression qui a encore trois droite
aujourd'hui il ya une droite une oie
d'identitaires qui est celle de zemmour
et et le pen une droite conservatrice et
régalienne qui est incarnée par pécresse
et puis une droite libérale et
européennes qui est plutôt incarné par
macro est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
cette
vision cette nouvelle cette nouvelle
rené rémond dad oui
concernant la concernant de la droite
identitaire effectivement on peut pas on
peut pas y échapper zemmour est
effectivement font partie de cette
droite identitaire même si je ne suis
pas forcément d'accord avec l'opinion
que l'on voit dans les petit peu dans
les médias ou ailleurs selon laquelle sa
part ça peut être un autre débat sur
laquelle zemmour par exemple serait
serait fasciste
s'attendre à ce que j'ai lu ça c'est je
pense pas que ce soit le cas mais bon ça
c'est autre chose que la droite
identitaire effectivement est-ce que ce
qui valut à le maquereau et de droite ça
c'est une grande question c'est une
grande question en tout cas il est pas
content non pas de gauche mais qui ont
servi à merveille les soutiens comme
edward bien sûr comme vient de le faire
comme toi darmanin il a qui viennent de
la droite et s'ils viennent une droite
ont étayé et kehl ado peut appeler la
droite moderniste et européenne on ruine
absolument je mettrais plutôt presque
macron sur le même plan que valéry
giscard d'estaing en réalité ce centre /
centre-droit effectivement se trouve
enfin se sent tous ces grands centres le
gouvernement charest et concernant
effectivement à valérie pécresse oui
elle réussit pour l'instant ce que
disait geoffrey tout à l'heure elle
réussi pour l'instant à incarner alors
on verra plus tard mais incarner cette
droite un petit peu je vais employer un
terme qui n'est pas un pion pas
scientifique droite attrape-tout dans le
sens où elle est elle réussit à capter
des des éléments des éléments
biologiques sur le régalien sur ce qui
fait la droite traditionnelle forte une
réforme plus de sens de l'état mais
aussi avec une vision quand même sur le
plan économique assez libérale est donc
finalement elle réussit à capter très
large il faut se situe faudrait que ça
c'est super ce secteur entre toutes les
veuves une chose d'être au deuxième tour
en tout cas en tout cas dans son dans
son parcours durant les primaires le
congrès c'est qu'elle a essayé de faire
maintenant c'est de réussir à le
maintenir ça c'est autre chose
fabrique de kerpel vous avez vous avez
participé à la primaire ait l'air ou
alors oui moi j'ai j'ai voté à la cette
primaire nerfs j'ai voté pour eric
ciotti bien sûr et un homme parce que
pour moi valérie pécresse qui se
considère comme une héritière de jacques
chirac en fait m premier tout mais ne
fera rien elle a un discours très à
droite parce que aujourd'hui c'est ce
discours qui a qui étaient omniprésents
dans ce courriel r parce que ben en fait
on a une droite on avec 39 % des
électeurs lr qui ne veulent pas d'une
macro compatible première fois s'en
allèrent qui se connaît beaucoup plus en
les idées d'eric zemmour en votant avec
ce type après on parle des sondages ont
dit qu'elles à 17% en fait on est proche
ce congrès c'est normal benoît hamon
prenez 10 % après la primaire du gauche
un bon petit c'est d'ailleurs de gauche
étaient très très haut aussi un
donc se méfier de cet effet oui et en
plus le sondage ifop menée n'a pas pris
en compte l'effet du meeting puisqu'il
s'est terminée dans la jambe dimanche et
donc donc voilà après dire que mes
pécresse ne représente à droite
conservatrice enfin moi je ne crois pas
du tout la droite conservatrice pour moi
c'est sebha le mouvement conservateur
que justement nous a rejoint donc il
exhume lui s'inscrit beaucoup plus dans
cette droite conservatrice qui peut
l'être valérie pécresse pourquoi
emmanuel macron a peur d'eux aurait peur
de casser mais tout simplement parce que
c'est celle mes personnages mais en
femme au féminin bon tu donc voila moi
c'est ce que je pense maintenant quelle
sera la position d'eric ciotti et ben on
l'invite à l'eau à le rejoindre tend la
main à tous et à ses 3 2% des électeurs
qui ne veulent plus du maquereau
compatibles ou d'un compromis nice de
mâcon elles peuvent rios est intéressant
c'est parce que c'est vrai que bon il
représente une certaine partie ne sais
pas combien mehmed ii de la droite elle
est requis et qui avait noté ciotti qui
est plutôt tenté par par pas par zemmour
et qui considèrent en effet que que
pécresse c'est macron c'est la même
chose
comment comment elle peut faire l pour
eux ben sortir de ce cette difficulté
c'est vrai que quand vous disiez le son
son défi son challenge c'est de
rassembler c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
exactement ça et pourquoi elle peut
rassembler parce qu'en fait valérie
pécresse c'est vraiment la droite
crédible c'est le premier j'allais dire
projet qu'on entend pourquoi il est
crédible parce qu'en fait elle fait elle
a prouvé que quand elle dit elle faisait
justement est en fait c'est la
différence d'ailleurs avec emmanuel
macron quand on dit qu'elle est
maintenant compatible je pense qu'elle a
énormément de différences si on
développait je peux évidemment
développer mais je pense que en fait
c'est une droite de bon sens une droite
de crédible et une droite qui fait ce
qu'elle dit en fait de bon sens parce
qu'effectivement
quand on parle sécurité
c'est vrai qu'elle est extrêmement forte
sur la sécurité je pense que c'est ce
qu'attendent les français et la sécurité
n'est pas uniquement un sujet d' extrême
que ce soit eric zemmour ou marine le
pen c'est comme l'écologie qui n'est pas
un sujet forcément rattaché aux
écologistes c'est une écologiste qui a
qui a vraiment trouvé des solutions dès
son arrivée en 2015 à la région ile de
france donc c'est une candidature enfin
pragmatique de bon sens qui a des
convictions extrêmement fortes qui a une
énergie absolument sans borne et une
détermination sans borne et qui fera ce
qu'elle dit contrairement à ce que l on
entend et à ce que wandrille disais à
l'instant là vraiment on c'est vrai que
en choisissant valérie pécresse c'est
vrai qu'on a cette certitude elle l'a
prouvé à la région donc elle le fera
pour la france est ce que vous pensez
masqueront dit beaucoup valérie pécresse
a gagné politiquement le congrès mais
celui qui a gagné idéologiquement c'est
eric ciotti
ce qui est pas fou me semble-t-il mais
bon si vous voulez ce
nom sait ce que c'est vrai que encore
une fois la campagne la campagne
à la terne de l air l a porté
essentiellement sur ces sujets qui sont
les sujets
nos qui sont ce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils
sont traités par ces mots à l'open pas
forcément le pouvoir d'achat aux
préoccupe probable en plus de français
que l'émigration bien sûr qui est
relativement faible
vous pouvez vous rassurer à bon compte
en disant que c'est des trucs d'extrême
droite et la droite et match mais c'est
ce qui préoccupe les gens osent de new
york où il faut s'il faut sortir
certains quartiers faut bouger un petit
peu vous feuilletez les gens il s'est
passé pas grossier s'intéresser au
problème de l'immigration c'est bouazza
benhamama française c'est la grosse et
kaboré celle du stalinisme alors me
voilà le mot à la française ok
ces légumes du discours de ciotti est
bon oui c'est
jeudi n'a pas été élu non on va pas non
plus passer toute la journée a toujours
parlé de ceux qui ont été battus pour ne
pas s'intéresser à celle qu'ils avaient
vu des qualités qu'elle a voulu
recentrer le discours ciotti a dit c'est
un mauvais c'est un mauvais signal mais
j'avais une question vaut alors aux
juristes il ya une proposition de
valérie pécresse qui consiste à vouloir
différencier les peines selon le lieu
d'où l'on vient ce qui a priori
après on peut on peut peut-être changer
la constitution on a aussi le droit ça a
été ça a été le vrai fond alors oui
c'est effectivement un constitutionnel
puisque on peut pas faire de différence
entre laquelle entrent effectivement
entre le quantum de peine en fonction
d'une commission de l'infraction donc ce
que proposait valérie pécresse était
totalement inconstitutionnelle et ça ça
a été à mon avis le vrai problème du
débat et l'air c'est qu'ils ont voulu se
positionner sur ce thème de la sécurité
et qu'ils ont fait tous la course à
l'échalote en proposant alors on parlait
de guantanamo à la française on parlait
de la circonstance aggravante en
fonction du lieu de commission de
l'infraction il me semble que xavier
bertrand avait proposé aussi une autre
du nouvel outil de l'immigration un
référendum
ou une autre ou la création d'une
infraction qui n'avait absolument aucun
qui n'avait absolument aucun sens et ça
ça a été vraiment peine aussi les
plaines automatique voilà c'est ça la
lorette le rétablissement des peines
planchers bon ça a été le la course
véritablement à la mesure la plus
inconstitutionnelle possible dans la cas
de vue du débat et l'air est ça aussi ça
va être mon avis un de leurs grands
grands sujets d'une grande difficulté de
gagner
et là pour le coup je vous rejoins
totalement c'est vrai que en tout cas on
voit que immédiatement après l'élection
de valérie pécresse où elle était déjà
portée par une sorte d'élan lui a dit
attendez moi je peux quand même me
prévaloir de 39% des voix des adhérents
qui m'ont été accordés sur la base de
certains sujets que j'ai développée dans
le cadre des débats qui ont eu lieu donc
il serait peut-être bon que voulez
récupérer un petit peu aussi et c'est
bien pour ça qu'elle a dit qu'elle
allait pimentée et c'est pas neutre de
dire qu'elle allait pimenter son
programme pimenté c'est forcément du
côté de ciotti c'est pas du côté de
xavier bertrand pour pimenter c'est
assez dur si enfin
non effectivement sur le plan
constitutionnel la loi s'applique
partout donc ya pas de sa proposition
n'est pas réalisable par contre se faire
demain par là je parle sous le contrôle
du pénaliste il semble que le procure la
république peut en fonction du lieu où
il est avoir une politique pénale un
petit peu plus les différentes selon les
régions sur les régions selon les
endroits en fait des endroits où il se
trouve il y aura une interprète alors il
y aurait une interprétation alors il y
aura une interprétation en fonction si
elles existent déjà
oui tout à fait effectivement en
fonction des orientales en fonction des
lieux de commission de l'infraction le
parquet va avoir alors c'est aussi c'est
pâques fonctions que du lieu c'est aussi
fonction de la personne qui va être mise
en cause le parquet va pouvoir avoir
plusieurs interprétations et plusieurs
prérogatives sur ce qu'il fait de la
personne qui est justement mise en cause
est ce qu'il le renvoi devant un
tribunal et ce qui saisit un juge
d'instruction à ce qu'il propose une
mesure alternative mais bon ça ce sont
des choses qui existent déjà dans la
justice du grand étudiants mais qui ne
dépendent pas seulement et du procureur
et du luth commission de l'infraction
mais également aussi alors premièrement
du taux d'encombrement des juridictions
et également de la personnalité de la
personne qui sera mise en cause est
d'accord on fait surtout la la c'est pas
tellement sur des lieux géographiques
c'est sûr des des infractions genre on
va mettre le paquet sur les stupéfiants
où on va mettre le paquet sur les
violences faites aux femmes
mais il n'y a pas aujourd'hui le parquet
va pas dire tiens on va attaquer la
problématique sûre d'elle telle ville
sort des régions c'est plus sûr sur les
infractions en tant que tel alors l'un
des problèmes de de valérie pécresse
avait très justement on l'a vu comment
conserver la droite et se recentre et
parce qu'il faut quand même se recentre
et si on veut parler à tous les français
si on veut être au deuxième tour c'est
une des questions à poser à au directeur
de campagne de valérie pécresse patrick
stefanini où les gouttes on est comme
les valérie pécresse très ferme sur le
régalien et pas seulement ferme en
paroles parce que la désignation d'une
femme pour la première fois dans
l'histoire du mouvement gaulliste pour
l'élection présidentielle c'est
évidemment une nouvelle quelque chose
d'inédit mais la politique c'est pas
genre et ce qui est intéressant dans la
désignation de valérie pécresse s'est
pas seulement qu'elle est une femme mais
que c'est une femme courageuse une femme
déterminée avec un mental d'acier et
sa formule la formule qui nous a permis
je crois de l'emporter dans cette
primaire c'est le courage de dire et la
volonté de faire madame pécresse est une
femme d'action sur les sujets régaliens
elle est extrêmement ferme est là elle a
rédigé 2 proposait deux projets de loi
constitutionnelle l'un sur l'immigration
l'autre sur la sécurité intérieure et la
lutte contre l'islamisme et donc ça
c'est pour la droite et pour les le
gauche ou en tout cas pour le reste de
l'opinion publique on va s'adresser à la
classe moyenne à l'électorat populaire
et à la jeunesse
voilà donc on va s'adresser à
l'électorat pour l'instant c'est un peu
vague legault le côté le côté gauche
mais le côté recentrage a en tout cas il
ya ya ya une question - khimki matin ça
va bien il ya toujours eu lieu qu'est ce
que ce qu'est ce que c'est la droite
républicaine y ait toujours eu cette mur
qui avaient été définis par chirac ne la
frontière pas de porosité entre la
droite républicaine et et l'extrême
droite il est cette fameuse phrase de
michel moi il vaut mieux perdre une
élection que perdre son âme beaucoup on
a vu où ils ont tous une île et le
desserrement des quatre mousquetaires ne
trompe donc non mais je sais bien mais
bon c'était c'était une phrase qui
résume est un peu cette théorie et puis
oui tendance pasqua d'ailleurs qui était
plutôt pour on peut avoir des valeurs
communes avec l'extrême droite ça ça
marche tant qu'on a un programme quand
même différent à partir du moment où un
un programme qui va
jusqu'à reprendre des thèmes de zemmour
et le pen est ce que cette frontière
étanche entre la droite et l'extrême
droite encore une raison d'exister
c'est la grosse difficulté 2 de la
droite dans la configuration politique
actuelle c'est à dire que valérie
pécresse elle est complètement enclavé
entre macron alors on se posait la
question de macron est il de droite en
tout cas ils occupent intello qu il
occupe en tout cas les victoires
largement
favorable à la droite habituellement et
puis de l'autre côté elle à un une
extrême droite zemmour le pen qui est
excessivement forte et donc en réalité
35 donc elle est quand même bien obligé
pour se créer un espace d'aller
récupérer à sa gauche et d'aller
récupérer aussi à sa droite donc à mon
sens ça eu du sens de faire un vrai
cordon sanitaire entre cette droite
républicaine et une droite qui pourrait
l'être un petit peu moins et qui pourra
avoir des tendances un peu plus
extrémistes lorsque il y avait justement
moins de deux puissances de la part de
cette droite extrémiste maintenant qu'
il ya des théories qui sont quand même
beaucoup plus
auquel les gens adhèrent beaucoup plus
dans dans la société sur l'extrême
droite ça me semble être plus compliqué
pour cette droite républicaine qui
historiquement existe de dresser ce
cordon sanitaire au risque de ne pas
avoir le nombre de voix suffisant pour
aller au second tour ou pour
éventuellement brider une élection
annan cabrio là dessus mais alors moi je
pense que c'est là où elle est forte
parce qu'elle a un projet absolument
équilibré je vois pas pourquoi
systématiquement on assimile les valeurs
de d'ordre et de sécurité
à l'extrême droite en fait tous donc
eric zemmour ou marine le pen je pense
que aujourd'hui les français c'est pour
eux une vraie question d'ailleurs je
reconnais à eric zemmour
le
j'allais dire
il a permis de traiter justement de
fissurer un peu le politiquement correct
autour de la sécurité la sécurité est un
projet est un sujet qui intéresse
l'ensemble des français et je pense que
valérie pécresse est très effectivement
motivée par des solutions pour la
sécurité l'immigration
et comme l'a dit patrick stefanini elle
a déjà ces deux projets de loi
constitutionnelle qui sont rédigées pour
vous dire à quel point elle est dans le
faire et elle est aussi
par conviction dans le social dans
l'écologie dans l'innovation
et donc c'est là où est tout l'intérêt
de son de son projet c'est un projet qui
répond à la grande majorité des français
dans leur ensemble et c'est vrai que
quand on voit que emmanuel macron à
plusieurs reprises à lui même
j'allais dire un peu familièrement taper
sur ses propres forces de police c'est
vrai que c'est des choses
des choses impensables de dire les
forces de sécurité ont besoin d'être
soutenus et je crois que là il n'y a pas
besoin d'être au rassemblement national
ou chez eric zemmour pour avoir ces
valeurs d'ordre et de sécurité c'est
voilà donc je pense que c'est un projet
parfaitement bien et qui te plaît
voilà vous êtes d'accord tout cet argent
charlène ailleurs il ya un axe que
mme aubry de guerre call vous elle vous
êtes vous seriez pour un la fin de cette
frontière étanche entre la droite et
l'extrême droite
c'est quoi l'extrême droite ce qu'ils
veulent c'est par exemple jetons plus
quoi c'est ce qu'ils veulent en tout cas
renversa république je pense pas qu'il
existe
aujourd'hui on peut dire n'importe quoi
aussi mauvais
après
oignons rouges du établie par
l'américain moi ce constat encore en
fait puisque on assigne au bouche à
droite qui y perd et ans où on a des
percutée comme eric tener qui se sont
fait excuser du parti parce que trop
proche de marion maréchal-le pen et puis
le résultat c'est que au centre on se
retrouve avec un certain nombre d'élus
qui se mettent tous à rejoindre emmanuel
macron et la majorité présidentielle
voilà moi je pense qu'il faut il faut
avoir un peu de cohérence est ce qui est
beaucoup manqué la famille d'alpiq 1 et
l as cette cohérence elle a beaucoup
manqué notamment en en laissant ses ce
congrès ouvert avaler pécresse et xavier
bertrand qui qui revêtent n'était plus
aux partis qui ont claqué la porte du
parti parce qu apparemment trop à droite
moi je trouve ça dommage maintenant du
coup ce que ça donne donne des adhérents
qui sont pas vraiment minutes ont l air
qui ont tous pris leur carte pour aller
soutenir leur champion ou leur
championne et donc moi moi je pense pas
que une liasse unicité là dessus nous
passent à autre notre vie juste une
petite question moi que je me pose c'est
dire qu on a vu une droite qui est dans
la campagne qui est très sûr la france
du passé sur c'était un peu le c'était
mieux avant une campagne électorale ça
se gagne sur le rêve
est ce que cette droite un peu voilà
scrogneugneu est ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle est est ce qu'elle va faire
rêver est ce que au fond l'optimisme
l'avenir c'est pas mieux incarnée par
macro quoique équipe d'un type par par
nature optimiste voilà qu'est qu'il veut
faire des choses
32e 12 20 45e vague
l'europe il varie va proposer il ya les
allemands qui sont pour le fédéralisme
il veut il peut y avoir des choses très
nouvelles qui me sont ils fait l'effet
d'établir fra - mais non pas de registre
mon pote non non pas du rêve parce que
la situation fait pas rêver en tant que
tel mais oui mais c'est
vite dit la droite devrait envoyer du
raid et pas macro l'inversé tout bien
vous avez faire coter savez d'un côté
des gens qui vous disent la france est
fichu et là il faut des immigrés cette
terrible situation exacte et d'un autre
côté un type qui vous dit la france a la
chance est là elle est formidable elle a
des réserves formidable elle peut elle
peut elle peut gagner encore c'est quand
même salaire la différence et c'est ça
que j'appelle le scraigne
mais non c'est sa tante oui alors pour
le rêve je ne sais pas parce que sur les
précédentes élections présidentielles je
suis pas sûr que les candidats ou ceux
qui ont été élus et est envoyé du rêve
pas du rêve il ya quand même rien et
lormont années normales de saison
ou alors on y croit encore c'est ça
c'est très bizarre d'ailleurs pas sa
recette quelqu'un aussi du sao si oui
alors ian d'sa après je pense que sur
l'élection de 2022 ce qui va se jouer
c'est peut-être pas tant le rêve n'est
le scrogneugneu mais c'est peut-être
plus tôt le réalisme le réalisme et le
pragmatisme et la capacité peut-être à
réagir ou à réagir et à s'adapter aux
circonstances je sais que j'ai raison et
peut-être parce que sa celulle une loi
de ces élections il ya aussi de dégager
il ya aussi voilà c'est la difficulté de
macron elle sera là est ce que il ya on
est quand même dans une société où le
changement on veut changer vite et le
fait que si valérie pécresse était au 2e
tour du fait que ce soit une femme je
pense est un atout fort ça peut être un
atout ça peut être mais c'est
effectivement est ce qu'on sait par
exemple pardon est ce qu'on sait s'il ya
encore ce parent % 2 % delà de 3 % de la
population qui disent moi je voterai
jamais pour une femme
on s'est souvent c'est facile des
sondages mais ça peut ça peut jouer
aussi que dans une élection qui se joue
à très peu
évolué quand même aujourd'hui enfin
obtenu de l'air du temps pas possible et
faire ce genre de sondages ce serait
mal à sortir ça fait beaucoup de mal à
trouver son public je pense que c'est
qu'il y va parce que de l'autre côté il
ya des autres qui voteront parce que
aussi parce que c'est une femme et je
pense que
âme si vous vouliez à rajouter quelque
chose sinon passeront passé au deuxième
tome peut-être juste très rapidement
avant de rêver je pense qu'il faut
retrouver une colonne vertébrale je suis
d'accord avec votre invité en plateau je
pense que
l'un disons qu'avec emmanuel macron
c'est vrai que c'est un enthousiaste
valérie pécresse aussi à une belle un
bel élan un bel enthousiasme aussi
mais je pense qu'il faut retrouver une
colonne vertébrale et une certaine
sérénité
avant de rêver et je pense que c'est un
peu la nature aussi de ce projet pour qu
avec emmanuel macron on était un peu
aussi dans un bateau ivre
de quelqu'un qui qui qui qui est
toujours joyeux mais qui dit aux gens ce
qu'ils ont envie d'entendre
qu'ils
distribuent pas mal de chèques à droite
à gauche en disant bon bah voilà
l'argent en fait voilà c'est pas c'est
pas un problème et c'est donc je pense
qu'il faut il faut reçu bardon est ce
que je vous interromps juste parce que
quand on entend dire oui c'est un puits
sauf honda dépenser beaucoup d'argent
est ce que est ce que la droite anne sa
place aurait fait différemment est-ce
qu'elle aurait laissé des entreprises
mourir le chômage
en face pas d'un extrême à l'autre mais
peut-être une plus grande maîtrise de
l'argent public oui ça je pense que
c'est un petit peu le sens de aussi du
projet de palais
à la crise sanitaire qu'on vient de
vivre pendant 18 mois c'est peut-être un
peu facile maintenant de dire bah nous
on aurait peut-être dépenser moins
d'argent je pense qu'il a enfin
honnêtement je pense qu'il a bien géré
comme il a pu malgré les vents il ya des
cafouillages au début mais qui l'a
particulièrement bien géré cette crise
où on a un chômage qui est bas on a des
entreprises qui repartent fortement avec
une croissance et
peut-être facile par rapport à une
situation dramatique
mais un flottement la quête au moins
sur ce plan là
sanitaire nous posions la question de
savoir si macron était à droite ou trop
à droite a priori d'après la droite il
est peut-être trop à gauche
allez on va passer à bas l'otan dont on
parle avec ses beaux c'était il ya eu
l'appel nuls meeting
[Musique]
est-ce que vous connaissiez thomass
bernard sun
basse essaie de lui cette aide du sictom
aspect regard scène c'est un musicien
dans la musique et et je vous dis ça je
me suis un peu renseigné utilisé pour la
promotion de nombreux films comme avatar
pirates des caraïbes
harry potter davinci code
dark knight interstella bon choix ouais
bon soit il
et d'aurélien web et d'un bal seul
[Rires]
et vous ayez bien philosophe
bas va pas vendre et il vous étiez donc
à ce meeting vous avez été soulevée par
la foule est là et les deux oratoire de
d'eric zemmour alors alors oui moi je
pense qu enfin j'ai trouvé ce meeting
l'incroyable y avait des après quinze
mille personnes y avait 900 jeunes qui
s'étaient mobilisés pour organiser ce
meeting avec l'aide d'olivier b d'acs
qui est le coordinateur national de tous
les éléments de l'examen vous qui avez
oublié ce métier faut savoir que ce
meeting a été organisé en trois jours en
trois jours parce que ban devait
normalement être vigilent de paris et
bien soupeser né pouvait contenir que
6000 personnes on s'est retrouvé tout de
suite à flot d'inscription et caetera et
du coup il fallait trouver une solution
donc on a choisi villepinte
alors villepinte moi j'ai trouvé que
toutes les personnes qui sont venus
étaient assez courageuse puisque avec
toutes les menaces des antilles faa et c
est aussi de la conseillère
départementale de seine-saint-denis qui
voulait qu'ils voulaient qui voulait
amener ce meeting enfin moi j'ai trouvé
ça dingue j'ai trouvé sa bonne passe
cuba y avait une certaine ferveur
populaire il n'y avait pas que déjà
nanti des classes aisées et c'est qu'ils
étaient c'est ça qui a fait la force de
ce meeting c'est qu'il y avait deux y
avait tout - toutes les classes sociales
étaient représentés j'ai trouvé ça
incroyable je suis trouvée sans quoi
vous c'est parce qu'il bat sara montrer
qu'on n'est pas là il ya quand même les
violences qui ont accompagné ce meeting
violence une à l'égard de 2 mg ou
d'ailleurs et puis les autres notamment
à le garder les militants de sos racisme
ça pose en commun à vos problèmes et ce
que la violence est inhérente au
discours de m alors non moi je pense pas
moi je pense que justement le ceux qui
se proclament comme les plus grands
défenseurs de la liberté d'expression il
m'a en fait tu veux le faire taire avec
gimont sos racisme ont fait circuler un
tract et un visuel en disant il faut
arrêter avec ces mots paris fera taire
eric zemmour on voit très bien qu'il ya
le logo des sources précisent ils sont
venus ils ont fait le choix de venir le
compte des risques dans ce meeting je
pense pas que si moi je vais un meeting
de jean luc mélenchon je sois très bien
accueillis avec un tee shirt vendu donc
forcément après alors je condamne toute
violence en 2d du côté alors maintenant
il faut il faut aussi assumer les
conséquences moi je pense que faire de
la provocation ça sert à rien je pense
que ça ne fait que s'aggraver ces
violences et les élus et les
initie les fractures après on a eu un
exe mots qui s'est fait aussi pendant
qu'il arrivait sur la scène qui s'est
fait sauter dessus par un militant
d'extrême gauche qui était en garde à
vue je crois en ce moment moi je trouve
ça dingue qu'on va une on veut l'abattre
c'était cet homme qu'on va le convainc
de violenter et c'est le faire taire
parce qu en fait la liberté d'expression
c'est quoi la démocratie c'est quoi eh
ben il en sait que toute personne même
si logiquement elles sont différentes et
kido logiquement on ait envie de jouer
de se détruire et bah en fait on vole on
veut que tout le monde ait la parole il
louvoie
croyable ces militants de sos racisme
était au fond de la salle n'ont fait
aucune violence n'est même pas parler
puisque c'étaient les t-shirts qui
faisait halte au racisme et qu'il y ait
une violence à leur égard de cette de
cette nature me paraît juste
hallucinante parce qu'on peut aussi
discuter avec les gens sans pour autant
leur donner des coups de batte de
baseball quand on voit cette femme qui
sort ensanglanté
évidemment que la violence est
déplaisante est que bon il serait on en
vient à regretter
les anciens service d'ordre du parti
communiste de la cgt qui savait
maîtriser quelque chose c'est vrai que
ça a manqué et ça manque dont beaucoup
de partis politiques maintenant il ya
moins de militants et moi l'absence de
service d'ordre c'est vraiment un
véritable problème donc tout le monde va
le déplorer et c'est déplorable et c'est
maintenant quand les gens de sos racisme
viennent avec un sourire angélique
maintenant nous dire oh bah on pensait
qu'on pourrait parler mais qu'est mais
sont-ils bête à ce point enfin gd c'est
une immonde provocation est ce qu'on
imagine mais est-ce qu'il est bien sûr
et ce qu'on y met des provocations
mais non qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire là
dedans si vous ils vont juste là bas
pour énerver tout le monde pour dire mon
temps où la regardais bill 1 on a pris
des claques et c est ce qu on imagine à
un congrès de sos racisme des gens
vandry et ses amis aller avec des
t-shirts vive zemmour comment serait-il
comment serait-il reçues s'est laissé la
vie c'est ça que je veux c'est la
violence qui
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
au delà de ça que en effet on est dans
une période très violente dont
l'affrontement dans le dans le discours
même nom de leur dieu sans appel à nous
raphaël vu d'ici c'est intéressant vous
disiez tout à l'heure quand on traite
les bords de fascistes on a tort
quand quelqu'un dit quand même pétain
sauvé des juifs qu'on remet en cause la
halle à l'innocence de dreyfus où je dis
pas que c'est du fascisme non mais ça
reprend quand même d'aider des éléments
ça reprend effectivement des éléments de
langage en 2d après faut se remettre
dans le contexte le fascisme a une on va
dire un mode opératoire assez
particulier et jusqu'à jusqu'à preuve du
contraire jusqu'à preuve du contraire
eric zemmour n'est pas n'est pas dans
cette lignée effectivement il ya des
noms mais il a des propos sur pétain sur
dreyfus d'ailleurs voilà je comprends
pas trop mais en mai
on va dire qu'il est valachie certaines
personnes je prend avec des pincettes
certaine perception de l'histoire mais
en tout état de cause la violence qui
est inhérente au fascisme là ne fait pas
en tout cas pour l'instant partie du
vocabulaire et du mode opératoire de
d'eric zemmour non c'est pour ça que je
disais tout à l'heure on ne peut pas le
considérer comme comme étant un fasciste
ensuite effectivement vous avez raison
la violence est totalement inadmissible
menthe même si je pense que il y a à
l'heure actuelle à l'heure des réseaux
sociaux alors de la télévision il ya
malgré tout peut-être un manque
peut-être ils ont peut-être que soliste
racisme a péché par naïveté
cette engeance par contre ce que je
trouve ce que je trouve inadmissible
quoi qu'on pense de zemmour c'est pas la
question se jouer d'admissibles sel
comme ali bendriss et que le
le président va des conseillers du
conseil départemental de de
seine-saint-denis et souhaitait
interdire que le meeting le métier je
trouve ça totalement inadmissible leur
la liberté d'expression effectivement
déjà il n'a pas la compétence pour le
faire d'une part et d'autre part il n'y
a pas meilleur moyen que et d'autre que
de promouvoir que de promouvoir zemmour
et et on s'est battus en el fassi plus
que la victimisation c'est au contraire
c'est une formidable publicité pour ses
meilleurs ennemis ses soutiens et ses
meilleurs amis si c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui le programme
en même temps il ya des phrases c'est
parti quand il met sur le même plan
quand il parle de ceux qui veulent sa
mort les journalistes et des djihadistes
et il a retrouvé d'ailleurs les deux
radios il était très bon tout ça
personne n'a protesté mme allier une
sorte de dodo de tolérance sur ce qu'il
dit qui me paraît assez assez incroyable
jean luc mélenchon était aussi un oui
très virulent envers les journalistes
absolument et mais ça lui a coûté sans
doute probablement et il a été très
virulent d'ailleurs sur le
disons que le seul france info a refusé
de prendre les images de ces équipes de
communication pour pour les passer sur
france info disant arabe et qu'il n'y a
que la radio publique qui refuse de
récupérer nos images de ce formidable
meeting qu'en ce qui est un peu
troublante quand même c'est cette grande
mode maintenant d'avoir des images qui
sont communiquées par des allées les
candidats rejettent elle comprend pas
alors qu'une des médias un minuscule
n'ai pas les moyens de le faire certes
mais que tf1 ou france 2 accueille les
images données par zemmour donné par
mélenchon c'est totalement aberrant ils
ont qu'à dire soit nos équipes sont là
bas soit on retransmet pas on n'est pas
là pour faire la publicité le
journaliste s'est pas la publicité c'est
pas de la communication tf1 soit là bas
d'après lui quand vous lui retirez les
deux heures de programmes râteau s'ils
sont très cool
ça c'est un dévoiement
de son enjeu genre peut-être sujet un
peu périphériques par rapport au meeting
de zemmour puisque on aborde le sujet du
journaliste je sais aussi que certaines
équipes de journalistes ont dû être
exfiltré oui du meeting de zemmour et je
trouve ça un petit peu alors simplement
une petite remarque de juriste mais sans
dire le fond de la pensée sur eric
zemmour je trouve ça un petit peu
dommage que l'on invoque la liberté
d'expression et une forme d'absolutisme
dans la liberté d'expression tout en ne
permettant pas à certains journalistes
de faire leur travail et à en couvrant
l'événement au motif que peut-être il
n'aurait pas eu à l'égard de zemmour les
propos que zemmour aurait bien voulu ce
que je vous ai ces derniers tiennent une
ascension directe serait ce sera
sur la seconde les journalistes en
question c'est l'équipe de yann barthès
quotidien journalistes comme moi je suis
évêque qui sont d'une liberté une
subjectivité totale et permanente va
devenir neutre avait besoin de cet échec
la liberté d'expression c'est parce que
c'est pas le journalisme c'est pas ça
c'est un métier le journaliste une
certaine objectivité mais il n'y a pas
eu le moindre objectivité de l2 avec la
bande de yann barthès on le sait très
bien de dire qu'on les traite comme des
amuseurs comme c'est très bien mais qu
elle ment quand le pape françois vous
avez nommé archevêque de paris
cet argument
vous avez un peu regardé le meeting de
zemmour et qu'est-ce que vous avez vous
pensé alors je le gardais le meeting de
zemmour une partie pas tout alors là
j'ai trouvé alors mon liberté
d'expression bien évidemment je trouve
ça scandaleux de pouvoir avoir l'idée
d'interdire
un meeting des l'hexagone donc
communication je trouve qu'il a très
vite appris alors après j'aimerais dire
un mot sur son clip mais je crois que
c'est un c'est un spot différents
donc il a très vite maîtriser la
communication avec ses promoteurs à la
obama il a été absolument performant où
je trouve en termes de communication
après c'est vrai que le problème d'eric
zemmour c'est que la france je pense a
besoin aujourd'hui de de fermeté mais
d'apaisement et que eric zemmour avec
ses propos excessifs et comme comme
mélenchon d'ailleurs exactement de la
même façon
ça ne peut pas être un projet crédible
parce que non seulement ça mettrait la
france à feu et à sang et un plus ce son
si vous voulez eric zemmour ne connaît
pas aller les arcanes il le dit lui même
il était journaliste polémiste est pas
un homme politique et je veux dire c'est
un tel métier on a besoin d'une telle
expérience pour savoir ce que l'on peut
faire est ce que ne pourra jamais faire
et donc je pense que c'est en cela que
le projet d'eric zemmour ne peut pas
être crédible
politique que je crois que pendant son
meeting il n'a pas déroulé de programme
il a annoncé le nom d'un parti mais il
n'a pas annoncé de bien pâles et quand
même de wiimote on met un peu de piment
symbole mais il va faire quoi quelle
action est financée comment est donc ça
on n'a pas de programme réel alors ils
démarrent qui devait annoncer alors je
voulais poser une question à monsieur du
gardien merci beaucoup je voulais ça va
comme vous êtes à l air est ce que
maintenant qu'un parti existe est ce que
vous allez quitter l air et adhérer à un
parti reconquête complète
alors oui j'adore partie rubrique est
pour l'instant les deux sont compatibles
alors est-ce que je suis encore accepté
chez les républicains mais oui j'y ai
adhéré au parti roquettes parce que moi
je pense que c'est ce qui ce qui pourra
en fait
la période disais tout à l'heure
il faut de la fermeté mais il faut de
l'apaisement pas de la fermeté mais en
fait sans fermeté il n'ya pas
d'apaisement donc je pense que le
discours d'eric zemmour et laisser le
monde parce que notre ambassade est
considérable aux solutions et les
solutions il les a il en a donné
quelques unes lors de ce meeting on dira
qu'il n'a pas des ouailles probable
qu'on le trouve je pense que vous n'avez
pas écouté les discours des exemples
ensuite
je pense que le ensuite pour revenir sur
le quotidien et c'est en fait le service
d'ordre a été hyper compétente parce que
justement quotidien si vous achetez pas
ils les ont exfiltrés et c'était pas du
tout contre la liberté d'expression
quand quotidien quand quotidien on
crache sur sur les soutiens d'un eczéma
mais forcément quand ils sont ils sont
dans un meeting où il ya des soutiens
avec six mois et vont peut-être pas être
forcément super bien accueilli
maintenant les arts on les a protégés
sur temps et après en plus si l'on veut
rentrer dans la salle donc dont voilà en
chinois je trouve ça dingue j'ai un
mythe anthony david croit d'air exe mort
pendant le meeting juste parce qu'il est
noir est bon le il reçoit des menaces de
mort etc il était hier son tempo pour
expliquer sa situation moi je trouve ça
juste parce qu'on noie on peut pas
soutenir les émaux et la liberté
d'expression et je pense que je pense
que
vous avez comparé au troisième sujet et
vous êtes l'incarnation de cvd vous
connaissez le nouveau tube de joséphine
baker
j'ai deux amours le second c'est ciotti
[Rires]
un
troisième 6 et guillaume
on va passer un troisième sujet
alors comme je reste un très intéressant
c'est le cas de nicolas hulot la sphère
île où
[Musique]
louis de faire nicolas est intéressant
parce que ça pose beaucoup de problèmes
moraux éthiques juridiques
voilà il ya cinq femmes qui l'accusent
d'avoir eu des comportements
de violence sexuelle ou de viol les
faits semblent prescrits
et alors on est partagés parce qu'à la
fois aux dits oui il faut évidemment
écouter la parole de deux de ses femmes
ses plaignante ni parfois de ces
victimes ont fait une saison différente
plaignants et
les cagnottes et en même temps si qu'il
ya une sorte de procès médiatique qui se
déroule dans lequel la partie accusée ne
peut pas se défendre pour moins se
défendre que s'il y avait un vrai procès
kokou vous vous regardez cette affaire
geoffrey soupe lui sous plusieurs angles
en réalité je vais essayer de tenir un
propos qui ne dure pas plusieurs heures
puisque n'améliorait y aurait eu
matériel dont vous plaît dans une demi
heure il y aurait il y aurait belle
allure et madjer a en réalité alors que
le premier à la première difficulté
c'est vrai c'est le tribunal médiatique
le tribunal médiatique qui devant lequel
s'est retrouvé de fait nicolas hulot
après la diffusion du reportage de
l'envoyée spéciale le problème du
tribunal médiatique c'est que il n'obéit
a absolument aucune règle dans un procès
pénal classique ou non une enquête
pénale classique il y a d'abord la
parole des plaignantes qu'on va
confronter un certain nombre d'éléments
objectifs et ensuite le mis en cause par
rapport à ces mêmes objectifs et à ses
paroles de commande pourra s'exprimer et
à la fin un le juge
déterminera s'il a suffisamment
d'éléments pour le condamner ou pas bon
là dans le cas de ce tribunal médiatique
on a un reportage qui dut pour une heure
une heure et demie avec la parole de
cinq plaignante qui sont en plus haut
confondant de réalité il faut quand même
le dire qu'ils s'expriment parfaitement
qui écrivent des choses très précises
qu'ils ont véritablement est a priori
marqué et ça rend quand même le la
possibilité de se défendre extrêmement
ténus et là le fait qu'ils aient
absolument aucune règle fait que bon bah
on en voit nicolas hulot face à ces
déclarations la et on lui dit mon bac es
ce que vous avez à dire par rapport à ça
nécessairement qu'il ne peut absolument
pas se défendre nécessairement que sa
parole sera bien bien moins investi que
celle des plaignantes qui ont été
entendus pendant plus d'une heure et
demie alors
là la question de la règle et de l'
équilibre à mon avis est extrêmement
prégnante et ce tribunal médiatique ne
permet pas parce qu'il existe on peut
pas nier cela est il ce tribunal
médiatique ne permet pas qui a un
équilibre entre la parole des
plaignantes et la nécessaire défense du
mis en cause puisqu'il n'y a absolument
aucune règle qui s'applique à ce
tribunal contrairement à celui de la
justice
il ya une chose qui est assez
intéressant c'est la prescription
d'habitude la prescription ça aide
plutôt les gens qui sont accusés puisque
au bout d'un moment il échappa à la
justice or là on a l'impression que la
prescription finalement elle elle agit
contre celui qui accueillit puisqu'il
n'est plus en mesure de se défendre
willy bail peut pas se défendre et pour
plusieurs raisons pourquoi la
prescription existent elles existent
parce qu'à bout d'un moment on n'a plus
d'éléments objectifs et tangibles parce
que quand 30 ans se sont pressés on peut
m'arriver a retrouvé des éléments
objectifs
qui a 30 ans et c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs les accusés n'arrive ne
peuvent pas se défendre parce que il
veut dire bah non il la seule chose
qu'ils peuvent dire c'est faux alors
sauf à avoir un nageur de 100 jours à la
maison je sais très compliqué la vraie
difficulté en réalité c'est que là les
pros que le procureur n'aura pas d'autre
choix que de classer sans suite au motif
que la prescription est acquise est donc
en réalité dans l'esprit de l'opinion
publique ce qui va se passer c'est que
nicolas hulot ne sera pas poursuivi au
motif qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment de
charges mais au motif que de toute façon
l'affairé prescrite donc ça ne ça ne lui
permet pas une défense sur quelques de
quelque façon que ce soit puisque de
toute façon la prescription s'impose aux
magistrats et à fortiori aussi à lui
doublement coupable c'est à dire qu'il
est coupable par le tribunal médiatique
puisque tout le monde va dire ben oui
y'a pas de fumée sans feu et et il doit
être coupable des faits dont on l'accuse
et deuxièmement abbaoui puis alors il
est coupable parce qu'il va pas être
juge et donc il s'en tire bien donc à la
limite il a 2 2 de fait à son encontre
alors que la prescription elle peut
servir quand même au parti saignant
absolument puisque en fait la
prescription elle existe pour pouvoir
dire aux victimes aux plaignants bah
écoutez va falloir que vous rajouterez
allez allez allez en justice il ya un
moment donné vous ne pourrez pas y aller
donc on a un coût près au niveau des
délais et les femmes qui ont subi ce
type d'agression sexuelle doivent à un
moment donné sortir de ce cercle dans
lequel elles sont il ya de cette
rumination sur ces faits extrêmement
douloureux et quelles qu'elles vivent
dans leur chair mais à un moment donné
il faut et la prescription est là pour
ça fait maintenant il faut y aller et
que je devienne un acteur judiciaire et
que j'ai une confrontation judiciaire
avec mes décisions
ces ambiguïtés de la lan de cette
affaire parce que il n'y a pas eu de
plainte au moment où il était au fait de
pouvoir parce que justement il a fait ce
pouvoir est en même temps apple
sentiment maintenant qu'on tire chez
renault lui lance enfin yaya voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est très compliqué
quoi un nom commun alors ravalison vous
avez
ça peut avoir finalement c'est cette
affaire de la prescription faire de
pleins de déposer postérieurement la
survenance de la prescription ça peut
avoir quand même une vertu si la
relation de judo qui se saisit
maintenant exactement exactement et là
où ça peut avoir une vertu c'est que par
une technique de filets dérivants on
peut avoir finalement del assure faire
la découverte d'autres cas qui ne serait
pas prêt ce que je serai pas frappé
pendant
le procès
exactement et donc là pour le coup
sourire est une phase judiciaire avec de
nouvelles plaintes qui permettrait à
nicolas hulot de s'expliquer sur les
nouveaux faits qui surviendrait donc de
potentiellement ouverts d'ouvrir une
phase judiciaire mais mais pardon mais
là où ça a été extrêmement extrêmement
complexe a rejoint le propos que je
tenais un petit peu avant c'est
lorsqu'on a dit un nicolas hulot bon on
sort l'enquète si vous voulez vous
pouvez apporter une contradiction à ce
qui a été dit ça mais ça me semble ça me
semble que ça me semble pas possible
pendant l' enquête on n'a pas accès au
dossier pénal on n'a pas accès au
dossier pénal donc oui il ya une enquête
et ça fait huit ans que le parquet de
paris engage des enquêtes
systématiquement mais mon cas de
prescription vendredi un mois
suivant tout à fait intéressant mais
hulot me paraît une sorte de
deux victimes deux des médias non mais
les
médias
on s'assoit sur la présomption
d'innocence
et
alors il y aura une conséquence
peut-être politique est-ce que ça plombe
la campagne de de jade au bahut - déjà
orphelins mathieu lancé voilà ce qu'est
ce que ce qui est pas un drame oui en un
mot parce qu'il faut qu'on se quitte
pardon un hameau en fait plus
humainement j'allais dire j'ai été très
émue par le témoignage de ces femmes qui
ont eu du courage de témoigner et je
voulais dire simplement que juste que
les que les hommes même si ça évolue
beaucoup hein mais que les hommes
prennent conscience qu'en fait pour un
moment passé entre une émission de télé
et le déjeuner en fait ils marquent au
fer rouge d'aider des femmes pour toute
leur vie et donc effectivement c'est une
prise de conscience et que les jeunes
hommes je trouve sont déjà très
différent de cette génération et que fo
pa al'inverse aller dans l'autre sens où
on peut plus s'amuser un peu dire ce
qu'on a envie de dire
sans sent tout de suite pour un homme
est retraité de harceleur ou de voilà
faut pas tomber dans l'excès inverse non
plus merci pour cette précision voyez
vous avez bien fait de rappeler aussi
que le thé bonheur de ces femmes étaient
très très important merci merci à tous
et bien bon se retrouve très vite si
vous voulez un poireau daf
[Musique]